so for decades they told us it was
essential the united states becomes
energy independent because we don't rely
on the middle east because they hate us
we have to follow these wars to preserve
our access to energy so we did become
energy independent
we produce enough energy for the entire
country in fact it's the most robust
sector of our entire economy so joe
biden naturally decided to crush it from
day one in office we had to do that he
told us because climate change and aoc
and all that
in fact it wasn't that long ago that joe
biden called for fossil fuel executives
to be jailed
we have to set certain guide rails down
now
so between the years 2021
and 2030 it's irreversible the path
we've set ourselves on
and one of which is doing away with any
subsidies for fossil fuels number one
number two holding them liable
for what they have done particularly in
those cases where your underserved
neighborhoods and you you know the deal
okay and by the way when they don't or
when they're deliberate put them in jail
that's what i'm from i'm not joking
about this
i'm not joking about it
okay so energy in the energy grid is
both incredibly complex and essential so
let's put a guy with a functional iq of
75 in charge of sorting it out that's
what we've done
and as a result of that gas prices are
out of control and people don't like
that
nobody likes out of control gas prices
because you need gas we don't have solar
cars yet
so now joe biden has changed his view
climate change isn't that big a deal
carbon emissions aren't a huge problem
not when they're coming from china or
the middle east but that doesn't mean
he's going to end his campaign against
our own energy industry they're still in
trouble facing prison time
instead joe biden today called on middle
eastern theocracies members of opec to
pump more oil
so gas prices here will go down what do
we make of this selena zito is with the
washington examiner she joins us now so
this i i don't think i've seen we don't
do a lot of energy stories on the show
but i mean i don't think i've seen a
more perverse and revealing policy than
this one explain what is going on here
if you would it's
actually it's sort of befuddling what's
going on you know the energy as you
pointed out the energy industry in the
united states has been one of the most
robust sectors
in our economy leading right before the
pandemic we produced more oil than any
other country in the world and we were
self-sufficient in that area and not
only was that a job creator
and not not only just directly within
the uh energy industry but also the
downstream industries that support it
and the communities that then thrive off
of it and then the school districts that
benefit for it it also was um
of very importance in national security
so which is i thought it was curious
today that the national security uh head
was telling or essentially begging
uh the opec countries
to
produce more oil
and and oil has been i mean the energy
industry joe biden has put his foot on
their neck since day one and that's not
and at least there's no exaggeration in
that statement from his executive orders
on the keystone pipeline to halting and
or pausing
production on federal lands with
fracking in in new mexico
and also oil production in louisiana
he's impacted lives american lives
profoundly right there
we've got to get energy energy
independent so we do now they're telling
us we have to be more dependent on the
countries that hate us in the middle
east this is a pretty dark moment i
appreciate you coming on tonight and
summing that up for us thank you thanks
for having me